نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه العربيه
العربيه ما زالت تواكب عمليه اجلاء رعايه
من جنسيات مختلفه والذين يصلون بشكل
متتابع الى جده الواقعه غرب السعوديه هذه
المره هي السعوديه سمحت بالفرقاطه
الفرنسيه لورين وهي واحده من الفرقاطات
العسكريه التي الان تحمل قرابه 400 شخص من
جنسيات مختلفه ويتبعون للامم المتحده طبعا
هذه الفرقاطه قبل نصف ساعه وصلت من الان
وهي الان في لحظات الاولى التي ننتظرها
لنزول
الاشخاص التي تقلهم هذه
الفرقاطه وكان اتحدث قبل قليل ايضا معنى
ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله السيد الطيب
ادم والذي تحدث ان هناك قرابه 400 شخص
جنسيات متعدده من امريكا والمانيا
وايطاليا وكذلك جنسيات من بعض اوروبا
الشماليه وصلوا على متن هذه السفينه بعضهم
يعاني من حالات صحيه وذلك ايضا دفع سلطات
السعوديه الى تواجد فرق طبيه وصحيه من اجل
رعايتهم وكذلك ايصالهم الى المستشفى
المخصص والمعد لهم وايضا نشاهد الجهود
الامنيه التي تقوم بها السعوديه من اجل
استقبال هذه البعثه او هؤلاء الرعايه
لنتحدث بشكل تفصيلي ايضا وايضا ينضم معي
ضيف جديد وهو الاستاذ محمد الغنيم وهو
ممثل في البرنامج الاغذيه العالمي مرحبا
بك استاذ محمد اليوم يعني تصل الفرقاطه
ولكن الفرقاطه اعتادت دائما ما تصل
السعوديه في تمارين مشتركه مع وزاره
الدفاع ولكن اليوم تسمح لها السعوديه
بالوقوف على الرصيف مي ناء جده الاسلامي
من اجل اجلام رعايه من دول عده من بورتو
سودان اولا كيف تمت هذه العمليه ما هي
المراسلات التي تمت بين الامم المتحده
وبين السعوديه وكيف ايضا
كان رد السعوديه في السماح لهذه الفرقاطة
بالوقوف على هذا الرسم
اولا اشكرك اخي العزيز على التغطيه
المميزه
واشكر صراحه المملكه الانسانيه العربيه
السعوديه على وقفاتها الدائمه مع العالم
بشتى
اصنافه
والوانهم حاليا
الفرقه الطلب تم عن طريق الامم المتحده
تم الطلب الى حكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالمساعده في اجلاء موظفين الامم
المتحده الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي ومن ثم اجلائهم عن
طريق طائرات الامم المتحده الى
محطات وصول مخطط لها
ابتدا بطلب من منظومه الامم المتحده لمقام
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ولا اخفيك سرا
كانت الاستجابه سريعه وايجابيه
مما كان له الاثر على العاملين لنا والاثر
الاكبر على المستفيدين للناس اللي كانوا
موجودين في في ميناء بور السودان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات